[Music]
i actually am not that big of a beard
drinker i like the occasional beer but
um
i drank very few of the cans that are on
the shelves here to be honest with you
my name is jeff lebo and i collect beer
cans and breweriana which is anything
having to do with beer history
my dad started working for american can
company back in the 1950s and so i sort
of was introduced at a very early age to
cans i remember when i was maybe five
years old we went in to see dad working
and i remember seeing all these cans
flying around i was just kind of
fascinated from a very early age
and then when i became a teenager beer
can collecting was really a popular
hobby among kids of that era from the
1970s and early 80s
it was one of those things that was you
know slightly naughty when you were a
little kid to be doing that sort of
thing but definitely worst things i
could have been doing
the group of collectors you know most of
us know each other to some degree so we
kind of know who has the largest
collections out there and unless there's
some closet collector out there that's
completely unknown to the rest of us
mine is the largest
[Music]
this was technically the very first beer
can that was ever produced this was by
american can company
and they had salesmen that would go out
to the breweries to try to pitch this
idea of this new can and this is the can
that they used to pitch this idea they
actually have opening instructions of
how to open the can
this was way before any kind of opening
device so you actually had to use what
they call a church key opener to punch
holes in the top to get at the contents
so the earliest
i've been in the hobby for 45 years now
and so i'm not an expert in many things
but beer cans is one of the things i can
say i am an expert in
these are cone top cans and these were
developed in 1936
so these are what we call party cans
four pint five pint and gallon size this
brand kruger which is from newark new
jersey was the very first
brewery ever to test market the beer can
back in 1935. this was done in i have an
auction company called cansmart auctions
and we do monthly auctions of beer cans
and other types of brewery collectibles
when i started doing the auctions i had
an idea of what i thought things would
sell for and
i have been surprised to find that
they've sold for way more than i
imagined if i were to sell off my
collections
via my auctions maybe three million
dollars or something like that
[Music]
i certainly didn't spend anything near
that i've built most of the collection
by trading over the years in the really
early days i would go out digging in
dumps looking for old cans i actually
went
diving in loch lomond in scotland
looking for pier cans so it's it's
really a lot of sweat equity that i put
into it to be honest with you
for many years i didn't have a place to
display the whole collection and it was
always sort of a dream of mine to be
able to do it so i just kept working
really hard and trying to save money
over the years and finally in 1998 i was
able to build the house for the
collection and the way i have it
organized is geographically and then by
can type too so
starting with the earliest types of cans
from 1935 so those have their own
section the cone top cans have another
section the gallon cans have another
section in that way i can sort of keep
things a little bit organized and when i
add things to the collection i can find
the section that they're supposed to be
in to see if in fact i need the can or
not because i only collect one of each
different can
you know in the grand scheme of things
we're all just specks of dust in the
cosmos so it's not particularly
important
but i like what joseph campbell said he
said follow your bliss
as long as you're not doing harm to
anyone else so that's kind of my
philosophy i like people who have a
passion for whatever it is they're doing
i may not share the passion but i can
appreciate
the passion they have for it i think
i'll probably just keep doing it you
know i'm sort of dug in now
there's not really any turning back
so i'll keep doing it as long as i can
[Music]
you